i'm currently with a bird yeah i don't
know what's happening i'm with a bird
too
he's the tutorial bird okay doesn't seem
to be tutorializing me very much
i'm about i'm coming in
hey
hey welcome to look how i strafe when
i'm crouched
hey i like your name choice look at this
nerd my scrim here
that's stupid am i peeing am i pissing
my pants what is happening yeah
you're both pissing your pants right now
it's pissing his back too
oh yeah we're very wet yeah all right so
there's a bird over here for you guys
maybe my bird yeah yeah uh-huh
huge in basically these stones
apparently represent things we need to
murder
the redstone it'll get there okay cool
sacrificial stones
slay the forsaken okay i can't roll i
can read it
i'm still soaked i am
just drenched well you were just up in
the sky
flying around very wet up high 1 000
bones guys guys guys
the goblin is coming what do you mean
what are you doing
buddy a goblin is coming look at those
hands
oh yeah oh my god he punched him in the
back of his head and he was like
nah ah skill improved unarmed bam
is that my story that's my stamina
what's
i don't know if we can hurt each other
here punch me see if you can hurt me bob
i don't know cool i feel great so this
is a game
that's like crafty survival yeah wait oh
there's a boar over here
veggies fired ecther register location
oh that show that puts a little mark on
your mappy poo
where el cather is or whatever his name
is oh wait am i skill improved for
running i see oh jump there we go
yeah guys you can improve your skills oh
yeah i get that stamina oh sacrificial
trophy hook attach item yeah if you get
the thing it's talking about but don't
do
he's dead now yeah i can see that his
blood's everywhere that's pretty
incredible
from behind the rock and scared me so
look these we got uh the bird said these
stones
represent the monsters we gotta hunt the
first monster
is it elk elk here i'm assuming we're
not ready we got a craft
dude oh it's got crafting okay it's a
crafting survival game oh
so we need how do we get another stuff
get hit beach
branch oh my god if you have found
a snack consume it to improve your
health and stamina
beware that before long you will grow
hungry again so try to always have at
least a couple different meals ready
you guys find any snacks over there no
i'm fighting a grayling whatever it
one of those means goblins is yeah what
trees gave you wood that you were able
to punch
it's on the ground you have to get
enough wood and stones to get an axe to
harvest from the big trees oh never mind
i still can't harvest from the big trees
or you can punch these little beach
trees like this where do you
where do you get stone i found a phone
stones on the ground though okay both
yeah
everyone talk all right on the ground
mark
pvp damage enabled no thank you
there's a switch for that apparently you
turned pvp on and off
is it on or off by default it's off by
default but if you
open your inventory and in the top right
click on the two swords
they cross and then you can pvp
yeah i'll leave that alone you guys need
me to craft anything i'm pretty good at
this
uh no i'm good so far i got my axe now
that's good new materials beach seeds
whoa oh we could play in a forest i
couldn't hold there's a
giant little tree log yeah i also
haven't made a ground look out
look out oh yeah
i hear a puppy barking well it's not
very not alive poppy is wrong i guess
i'm gonna craft a club
and also a hammer if you craft a hammer
you can build with it so you we can
build a campfire and stuff oh it can
build a thing
yeah guys i can make a cooking station
oh it's a deer
get it i'm trying it's fast i'm
very not oh that's a bore actually
wow you're a boar i killed that boy got
him
get better oh my god it's so far away
i'm waiting
around here are you the one hunting away
yeah yeah all right it's too fast i
gotta kill this grayling oh scared off
another one of my deer did you are all
the deer you're dear
yes you found us hey there's a house
over here
last there's a house over here
how do i can i repair it i have bees
oh my please bees
why are you covered in stank this is
babies
i'm sneaky they'll never they'll never
see me coming i think it's fine as long
as you don't whack it with a stick
right before you send that death
to you this is armed force now did you
guys
build stuff already i'm out of state i'm
out of sight we're out of the woods
don't worry buddy
i got him are you sure you didn't build
something there's like two
yeah we were talking about how there's
houses yeah we're literally saying that
out loud
i was busy chasing deer sure you were
it's getting dark it's pretty though we
should probably make like a fire or
something yeah
something like a fire or something i'll
make us a fire
don't even worry i'm not worried is that
a swamp
shrek look trick trick
my running's improving i think that i
what is that have you guys looked up yet
i see stars die oh
okay there's a the green tree
xbox the xbox there's a halo around this
planet
oh wait that thing it touches ground
over in the distance that away i don't
know why
but there's a base to it way in the
distance across this river
it wasn't a swamp it was actually a
river i feel cold
yeah why is there boss music guys
help i think i found shrek oh my god i'm
coming home oh my god i'm coming home
a little birdie popped up and warned me
not to stay away from the fire at night
when it's cold
guys i'm being like chased by a wall of
shadows
guys i made a house yeah bob's made a
house we're having a very different
experience
no it doesn't look like when i was down
by the river all of a sudden horrible
music started playing and it looked like
a wall of shadows was
pursuing me i was not happy guys i can
use the workbench now
oh wait bob did you build a hoe no i
don't have a builder
i will build a hole but work the earth
stone axe whoa wham
get worked [ __ ] are you working these
i'm working the earth
jeez i'm working it
i'm going to panthen i'm
i shall look back
wonder if i hold this if i'll stay warm
it is fire oh
maybe you can't use raw meat on the fire
why would you be able to you have to
make a cooking station
[Music]
is that what you're really here to tell
them
what do you mean it needs a roof i tried
to claim it from underneath you and it
needs a roof i was trying to build
everybody a bed you didn't even need to
steal anything
okay everything's got durability too i
noticed my axe is not looking so hot oh
god in the darkness the ghrelins are
scary
dude bro you grilling grilling the grill
and saw me chopped down the tree and was
like
no oh i'm gonna kick its ass i gotta
climb
come here wait you just got a club now
come on no no i've had a club
get on our level i've had a club i've
i've been i'm cool
i destroyed the phone no
come here if you knocked out a tree it
can domino other trees to death
be careful be careful oh the trees hurt
on you they make you injured okay this
is a dangerous game
i'm waiting for one of you two [ __ ]
through punching the law
knock a tree onto our base and destroy
everything again oh i don't have enough
stones for a stone axe
what is that noise oh it's a deer
kick your ass dear how did i get
feathered oh god one of my trees fell on
a bird
bird well we didn't he wasn't any use
it wasn't any use anyway it's all good
damn who needs them
wait there's a secondary attack why is
there a secondary attack or can kick
get kicked what do you what do you how
do you kick
you how do you do you middle mouse oh
boosh that's really funny oh
take this trick oh you can't with the
axe damn it guys we have a homestead or
something
there's a line on the ground and it's
growing
like wait get your hammer out get your
hammer out and look around
there's like an outline of like this is
our
area this is our land oh god building's
gonna be
hard do i have to think about this oh
god oh just smack it down come on all
right
just build a wall build a wall a little
roof filled door build a wall
build it you got it man there you go
i think my staggered roof here is really
going to make sure the rain
flows right onto us when we sleep look
at the door i built though it's amazing
wow you don't deserve to hit it i think
it'll work it'll fit right in there
our thatched roof cottage is perfect
i love i love the layers of the roof
exactly
we'll put rain collectors and it'll be
our shower
oh hey well one of these beds is more
exposed than the rest apparently
that'll be weeds the one on the end
can't be claimed
how do i build this beautiful oh no
how do you mark look at my roof
it's perfect it's so amazing all right
wade needs a little wall next to his bed
he's so good at making rooms man i don't
know man
yeah no that that bed is protected now
you can now sleep there
what i have done is adequate you know
what though i will say
so far the base building in this game
kind of awesome
kind of kind of cool i'm into a little
sick kind of sick
i don't have any kookables where do you
get cookable items
i don't know kill stuff fish can we fish
can you build a fish
to the bores i got some meat raw meat
off one of the bores
that's why i'm trying so i'm up to four
leather i think we need eight to make a
bow
i'm not getting a lot of leather off
these bores oh i found another one of
special stones what's this stone screw
this one
disaster where the grass grows under
foot and the skies blew overhead there
was always tears
wet i'm gonna get you in the river idiot
stupid you're done i'm swimming no come
back he's so almost done
who knew bob the deer is coming your way
go south go south cut it off i got you
buddy he's coming out of the woods
go south i'm chasing it yes yes yes kill
the deer
oh oh it turned i'm gonna shoot me yeah
i'm chasing it oh you're mine [ __ ] oh
we're gonna sandwich you
yes this is hunting this is hunting this
is hunting oh we're velociraptors mark
we're gonna we are the apex predators
did you guys just clever gorilla deer
yes
you know this peaceful violin music is
very nice i got flint
oh i can build a chopping board for
deadly frogs
called necks they're necks i'm sorry
what's happening
so many things happened is at all at the
same time oh my god
there was a bird sitting on the ground
and i was like i'll get him
and i took one step towards him and he
took off like a rocket
a thousand miles an hour uh that bird
was like
is this a pig i wonder if we're gonna
have to kill birds too to get feathers
for arrows
i'm about to die help pig assistance
where are you oh you're not that hard oh
i got here just in time to not be able
to do it no there's two
i don't worry guys got it all taken care
of thank you man don't worry
dear oh guys once you use your stamina
your stamina bar gets bigger
oh
you're telling me if i use it enough
bigger it'll get bigger you're saying
yeah if you play with it it gets bigger
i unlocked more crafting things by
picking up flint that's in like the show
no
help god oh my god i'm drowning
help me if you run out of stamina yeah i
was
drowning turn back this is a dangerous
place
you have wandered into the black forest
this place could be very dangerous
prove your worth by slaying ike fear
who's this [ __ ] bird trying to tell me
that i'm not worthy of going into the
black
forest sounds like it's a bird that
knows more than you do
take this bees
how do you kill the biggest single bees
that's because mark and i are out here
slaying bees okay i'm crossing the bird
seems to think i am worthy of this
why are you worthy ow bees
oh no god no
wait how have you not run into bees by
now we've both run into bees multiple
times
i don't believe there's such thing i
don't believe in it
you don't believe me i don't i'm a
non-believer all right i'm gonna try not
to run out of stamina and drown
some idiot that i wait guys sounds
pretty handsome though you know
even if he is dumb a box of rocks
tell you what that scared me this is
like killing
our house on the map because i don't
know where home is
uh we'll just remember a map you'll get
it
i'm killing a skeleton
yeah i see you mark dude i'm coming i'm
in the black forest
apparently this bird thought i wasn't
worthy but hey
oh my god what are you doing god i
dodged
oh i'm so good yeah you can die oh
you're up in a tower
oh my god the skeleton
you all right don't go up there i see
your death
don't go up there oh he's almost dead
he's almost dead
he hits so hard don't worry bob i'm here
to help
but be careful wait help i'm trying to
cheese it i'm trying to kill him from
like beneath
all right oh god oh you could fall off
all right wade your turn dude be careful
not
he's seriously dodged okay good keep
dodging
oh fell off he's dead yeah we did it
that was easy don't worry mark
that was really easy oh mark can we
revive you or steal your [ __ ] or
something
oh ah go get the little chest up here
yeah there's gotta be some good loot
oh man there is a moderate amount of
there's six feathers that's something
nice oh there we go mark we got all the
loot
okay come in i'll get my shares just
leave it there thank you
friends you're so good to me the bird
came back oh there's a bunch of ghrelins
over there
bob bob there's some scarier i told you
bro those guys these aren't just
ghrelins these are
these are founders i'll tell you
oh he's pointing spinning oh he's doing
juices
oh i'm dodging the juice dodging arrived
it's time for you pizza
guys we are murdering these creatures we
have no idea what they're
here for there's more [ __ ] him up
i'm out of stamina my stamina why are
you you know
you know my thing up in the top right
after i die it says no skill
throwing rocks but i feel like i've
drained a lot of skill because i used to
be a lot better my
my stamina bar was much bigger before
that's not enough hell i don't have
stamina to whack him so i'm not going to
come here why do i get it five no i
don't want to die please let me live
i wanna live sweet life
god punched you to death oh i have no
stamina
oh guys honey is delicious honey there
we go
i gotta finish this probably from
killing the beast
is this our house whoa chess yeah
oh yeah all right
did you get all the loot well yeah that
was my share right
where's our house mark you went home
yeah i'm going home
did you climb a bed i did not remember
where the house was i have no clue
how do you not i chased a deer around
for a long time and kind of like see the
map
yeah but i don't remember where on the
map our house was so you didn't claim a
bed is what you're saying because the
bed
shows up on the map i thought you told
me there was no bed for me
i made a bed for you and it's beautiful
and you're family
actually there is no bed for you man
there's no bed for you man i don't know
how to tell you this there's wait
bob has two beds there's oh wait did i
climb two of them
sorry wait there's no bed for you i'm
apparently only
the station is only one star
yeah but it says you have to like you
can try to upgrade the station
would you have a flint i could borrow
i've got
i need uh i guess i'm
wrestling i don't have enough to make
like a spear or an axe
no i was gonna make a chopping block i
think to chop off your head but i'm not
sure
i don't know if i have a legitimate for
you for that get speared
[ __ ] how do we give each other that oh
we put in the chest probably right
that is an option here you go mark i've
got five
i don't i'm over it man i'm hunting boar
where are you seeing
chopping block ah girl get speared
dude spear is dope secondary attack
i can throw it guys i'm gonna make a
beehive
right by our beds why would you do that
specific action because then
we'll get used to bees and then we won't
be afraid of themselves
to build up a tolerance to be i am
literally going to build a beehive
on your bed i'm i'm pretty i'm 100 sure
that's how it works i am there you go
buddy
check b the check b just need more open
space
oh well that's not great and i guess my
bed isn't spacious oh beach
god was that a dead what did i do what
all right i'll make a roof hive fine can
i
hang on can one of these beds can you
unclaim a bed no
i can remove it all right
i'll make you a bed buddy don't even
worry about it that's not a bed there
you go
i could have sworn you were about to
destroy my bed
no no no i'm a good friend wait claim
the bed
thank you can you guys sleep right up my
head did you know
did you name yourself mork before or
after i named myself at the same time it
was a coincidence
that's a weird coincidence
only bob had named himself bob over
there but whatever yeah
if i make a bow it's gonna be i'm gonna
be terrible with it oh guys i'm level
six
jumping right now dude the bees are
happy
oh
how do you throw harder that's what i
want to know oh wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait i
missed or did i 20 leather scraps
yeah we need 20 leather scraps 15 flint
10 wood five deer hide to make it
that's so much stuff so we could build a
raft we could play everyone's favorite
game
guys i'm improving my swim skill that's
pretty cool
careful fueled around no i'm fine it's
in like a tiny little pond what could
possibly happen i'm gonna spear this
beehive
oh
oh that bird is no more
so what are you throwing spears yeah you
can throw a spear it's
awesome i'm i'm on an island right now
getting mad
flint yo that is awesome man wade how
are you contributing
i'm currently permanently stuck in a
building menu and i can't get it to go
away
good good work wade oh you know what you
get extra stamina from
wow it's food yeah
yeah did you know that oh you thought it
was from playing with it
yeah i thought it was like experience
like you know wiggling it around
it's food it's food oddly enough shove
your face and it gets bigger
food always does that for me what if we
shove each other's faces
will that help more i'm prone to
experiencing you guys
shoving all kinds of things in my mouth
you're prone to what does that mean yeah
what do you mean
i mean i'm down for it oh that's
difficult
yeah because going down is going prone
right agreland just attacked me and i
hit him once and my club broke
and then i punched him in his stupid
face awesome
really satisfying the combat is really
satisfying yeah jesus
i hit that boring's butthole it could
not withstand it
did it explode uh yeah
yeah a lot from downtown
yes guys the farther you throw the spear
the more damage it does
oh my god that's pretty nasty
dude that deer was one shot
wash you want to watch how daddy does
when he hunts deep yeah i need to i
didn't just murder some deers
all right you you need you can even is
that the flint spear
uh yeah you see which one i'm going for
yeah
yeah the buck oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
have you gotten a buck yet because they
have a lot more health than that oh i've
gotten a buck all right oh i have but
it cannot withstand what daddy do
all right i'm about to take the most
incredible butthole shot you've ever
seen in your life
you watching so ready yeah three two one
it didn't die but okay and give me back
my spear tell you they had a
oh god no kill it wait kill it finish it
destroy it where'd my spear go get it
kill it
kill it dead hit it wade go sprint
daddy needs uncle's assistance come on
oh man that speeder was real expensive
it's so low on health how do you know
i just hit him with a spear that's not
oh no
okay come on i'm so close it's dead
there's no oh
come on right here no
don't go up the hill you think it would
bleed to death you think that
blood would be yeah spear right up its
ass like that
yeah downtown
oh so close you went in mark oh you know
what i lied about the meat
i i made apparently we made coal what
how did you make coal
by cooking a piece of meat and mark this
is not a dare
wait i can't help you i cannot help you
i can't help you uncle uncle's got no
stamina
he's got some claws in his ass from
downtown
god damn it good luck wade i'm gonna get
this deer it's coming could
really use a hand it has no idea it has
no
idea ah damn it
no idea we're all okay we're fine
yes yes yes yes yes yes
you're dead i killed you you're gone
you killed me i think he's talking to
you now
oh what wait you okay man if only my
buddy mark was nearby and could have
helped me prevent that horrible death
why did you run away from
your body is so far away why are you
over there
i kind of got ambushed by a bunch of
criminals
so run home i couldn't man
all right you know that's fair uh okay i
got some flint i got some deer hides i'm
bringing them back for the wealth to be
shared i'm gonna build more beehives
do do you have queen bees i do i do
get you some mark get your gadoosh
[Music]
missing requirement what am i missing
that would be oh apparently i don't have
two queen bees i thought i did
this feels like a trap i'm gonna fall
for it
excellent man you show that trap who's
boss water snakes that attack you in the
water
definitely those are fish never mind
that's a
um could be a log wait ah what did you
do
listen man i dropped this i chopped this
one
way up there look out grilling
don't worry i got him i don't know i hit
him here i can't chop this
log so good luck can i just
oh it looks like one of the uh no you're
right it's a regular log
destroy our home oh no i'm bare fists
oh god all right i'll take care of it
hey wait give me some of that wood i
need to
take that one i earned that i earned
that yeah i know you did that i earned
that i
am aware of what you earned this is the
picky went to market this little piggy
went home
one [ __ ] face all the way home
nice man nice so i'm gonna try not to do
that anymore
mark all right oh it barely damaged our
home
wait what there's nothing nothing
happened nothing
you guys almost told them what's going
on over here nothing happened
cook cook damn it do you like this pole
i built
is this your work yeah i put this here
you want it i you wanted to contribute i
see that now
wow i did build some of the walls but i
thought that this place really needed
something
i'm like half health but it's fine god
if we chop down this one
chunk here we are done for hey take your
meat
uh is it done oh
dude all right well goddamn
trees it went cold there's a real fine
line between
food and coal i didn't know this it got
cold real quick
um mark that thing that you were worried
about may have slightly happened
no wait why what are you talking about
what happened i i chopped down a tree
and it um
it cause some other trees to go down
i told you that's that's the best thing
but
also could be horrible for the
environment you know
just yeah whatever listen we're the only
three people in this entire world as far
as i know
you're right i guess it's kind of the
last of our species situations
so uh we should all have sex
oh no guys have you ever carried too
much
no no look look at my sad man
i'm trying to come home oh no dear oh
goodness
i can't move now let me oh someone left
some meat on the thing again and ran off
yeah okay you look i picked up too much
mark
you're so sad you're so
sad also you're dripping are you did you
go in the water easily you're carrying
too much mark i'm dripping
with stuff hang on oh
okay i'm better okay yeah you look
better definitely not dripping
pick some of those up yeah i got you i
got you man these beaches oh no i'm
carrying too much
[Laughter]
all right man you okay got me home
you look like you pissed your pants and
you're gonna hold it all in
i'm honestly i'm out i can't
yeah let me drop this one log again real
quick
okay there we go where were you keeping
that
uh nowhere all right i'm gonna get some
more flint no i'm not it's dark let's we
can we sleep till mornings other thing
we do
that'd be kind of cool maybe these tails
are gonna go to
coal ah screw them their tails who wants
there's
more where that came from yeah
this is this is
oh the synchronized stand up wait you
can still save the tails
i don't think yeah they're fine oh
they're fine how are they fine
oh that meat rejuvenated my soul
yeah dude you gotta eat the meat dude
meat what's up oh my god meat gave me so
much health
dude all right off to adventure my dad
all right
getting back to work i'm gonna go find
more deer yeah keep getting us deer
skins mark we need lots of deer skin
you got it first up boar kill of the day
oh
yeah brother i'm gonna work on getting
some flint so that i can also hunt
animals
well you wish you wish you could you
cannot
you wish man don't don't crush my dreams
like this
man i am an expert hunter oh my god with
the knife you can
jump attack whoa
oh that was a good hit on the deer oh
hey mark i scared you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and throw there you go
you can keep everything six inches away
from you yeah well pretty good
i picked up your flint sphere
there you go yes thank you
oh there's another deer over there wait
wait wait don't go that way there's
another deer
okay watch this you ready you watching
from downtown
dude one shot yes oh i should have made
one of those spears
dude i'm flint gathering right now so i
can make one
spears dope hey guys we just got an
urgent message
from downtown okay never mind uh uh i
didn't go through message got corrupt in
the light of the sun
i accept your death yes
god i'm a god what's it like to be
god it was just a
picture perfect shot like picture
perfect it was
beautiful like if someone took a picture
of it oh yeah
it was perfect oh yeah yeah oh my god i
chopped down the entire forest
oh yeah eat my ass
is that a requirement i have 11 flint
what did we need flynn for besides more
spears which
i'm gonna need eventually the the the
table thing the the cable thing
panning rack the structure now well the
tanning rack was something but there was
something mark wanted to build too oh
the chopping block i don't even know why
unless really it's just for chopping
people's heads off which that sounds
like a four but
if if that's the case i i mean well
we can always test it i really need a
spear
dude i'll uh make you a spear once i get
enough uh flint for
two i just did a leaping attack at a
boar which
missed horrifically but then i just
swiped him with my knife and he exploded
in
delicious beef nice man nice i love
killing things man god i'm glad that
we're just
all three independently horrifying in
different ways murderers
what do you mean who's horrifying
anyone watching this who would you
rather be murdered by
leave a like and a follow like comment
subscribe
ring that bell oh damn it mark i thought
you were a victim but you're marked
i thought also i sprinted so happily
just two murderers passing in the wind
i think i got enough for two bob i'm
gonna come back home soon and make you
one i'm
i'm i'm flinting up i i honestly i put
like 20 flint in my box already
oh okay i just uh what else do you need
for a spare
it's just wood i think it may be sure
there's a lot of flint a little bit of
wood
i don't feel rested anymore i'm not
rested guys i'm wet for two minutes
right now
okay i see a place where there are
definitely bees
oh hi hi boar also what is it what are
the bees for i forget i'm out of stamina
honey
which is like an obscenely good healing
thing if you're ever in trouble and you
have some honey
eat it i too see the bees
nailed it these deer have eyes in the
back of their anuses they know where i'm
at at all times
do you think if you had an eye on your
butthole it would just get like pink eye
all the time
could you feel that that would be called
the pink eye
i think all right would you like put a
contact lens in it
how do we upgrade this workstation
oh chill dear stop walking oh here we go
the butthole stab so the deer don't
actually give any leather they just give
the deer hide
boars are the things that give us
leather so far is that right well i'm
just murdering an entire family of
boars over here yes yes
gotcha yeah i have
uh two what is that deer hides i'm
making a chopping block
i'm doing it you can't stop me it is
happening no
don't it's happening wait
oh no mark i'm encumbered oh wait
no
[Music]
i did it is that oh oh
oh is that your head is it for head
shopping
it was the thing it was exactly what we
needed
the chopping block is how you upgrade
yes uh
okay how many how many leather scraps
did you need from me all of them as much
as you can yeah probably all of them all
right so
uh funny story funny story
i actually had eight and now i have
zero and you might be asking well how'd
that happen
well you might be asking that
no no no no no no no you might be asking
how that happened
and speaking of fire check out my
fire arrows look at this weight you
looking
yeah bam ooh can you reclaim that
nope the arrow is just lost yeah that's
unfortunate but it looked cool
we're so pretty cool everywhere we are
yeah we are
you like the name of the camp it's a
pretty good camp name
thanks man oh you know that's a pretty
good that's a pretty good campaign i
like that
yeah oh there's a whole lot of [ __ ] we
can craft now leather helmet
yeah oh that's pretty neat dude come
home we got new risks
i'm trying to kill these stupid bees but
they're not dying
hey let me help man let me help here let
me i'll help you
you want help can you help me yeah i'm
going to help you okay
where are you at where are you at here
i'm helping
here they're in here can you spear them
to death oh i can do better than spear
them watch this
you watching bob you watching i'm
watching
i call it the fire arrow it is
the most incredible
[Music]
oh my god oh yeah
oh the the queen's on the roof you get
it like
oh you got yeah yeah we have a lot of uh
resources my friends
that is pretty sick how much leather we
got
uh where's the is in here i just put it
in
like a random my god
grab these out i killed two deer in a
row
dude dude sick dude
all right i'm coming home beehive the
city is getting a little cramped
but uh you know they're happy all right
also i
i i'm loving this game but unfortunately
i am running
right out of time all right well should
we go ahead and save
save sleep i actually like this there's
there's a lot to this zzz my dudes
zz my dudesy
[Music]
you